[Music]
I came around the last hairpin and there
they were
but maybe 20 30 guys and then it's just
guns in my face got my hands up I'm
trying to be as cooperative as possible
had some rickety old peasant bus stop I
thought that was being robbed one guy
that seemed like he was in control there
they ordered me off the bike and so I'm
standing there with my hands up and
they're yelling and screaming to open up
my saddlebags and they're yelling the
Rope are open and that means clothes at
this point I think well this is just a
robbery and I'm actually doing mental
calculations well I can buy that again I
get this I can get that and you know be
cool and don't argue with these guys and
the guys waving his gun he's going okay
vamos I thought that he meant to get
back on the bike and that's not what he
meant
he was furious at that point he was
furious a guy was spitting fire so now
it's really escalated I'm trying to be
as politely non-compliant as possible
they're pointing to the back of this bus
and I'm going why do you want me behind
there and I said they're gonna kill me
no quiero here I don't want to go I can
never remember a time where I was
thinking that fast
[Music]
I just flat-out refused to go with him
don't get a viola I figured him off and
take a bullet there in front of
witnesses
it's a nice little key we just do it
here
he pulled a 9-millimeter out somebody I
wanna meet up ying cuenta does me notice
he chambered around and he pointed at my
face somebody went uh I think they're
gonna shoot me for sure there was no
doubt in my mind
absolutely none yeah it's a pretty
powerful moment when you believe that
you're gonna die in the next few seconds